[Music]
after an oil spill responders take quick
actions to decrease impacts to the
environment this ranges from containing
the oil spread using barriers to
breaking up the oil into small droplets
using dispersants or in some cases
burning the oil off the water surface
but when the oil sticks around long
enough Nature's Cleanup Crew arrives
namely bacteria that consume oil like
alkanovorax borcomensis while oil leaks
can be devastating to most marine
organisms alchinivorax thrives in these
settings communities of microorganisms
working together can break down the many
components of crude oil into carbon
dioxide and water
when alkanovorax borcomensis consumes
alkanes the bacteria form a biofilm
around the oil but it wasn't clear
exactly how this played a role in the
oil's degradation to find out
biophysicists set out to observe this
process in extreme detail
first they cultured colonies of bacteria
then let them grow and multiply for
different spans of time in a vial
containing a proxy for oil hexadecane
and artificial seawater they then
harvested these cultures from the test
tubes and mix them with fresh hexadecane
the droplets were then trapped in a
chamber where the researchers could
observe the biofilm formation through a
microscope
the bacteria sampled from the one day
old culture formed a thick biofilm over
the droplet mostly maintaining a
spherical shape as it consumed the oil
but the five-day-old culture did
something drastically different it
formed a thin biofilm around the oil
transforming the droplet into branching
dendritic tubes
so how does the same species of bacteria
degrade oil in such different ways
for one the dendritic biofilm sticks to
the oil better
previous Studies have shown that
alchinivorax gets more hydrophobic over
time which means the bacteria is less
attracted to water and sinks more deeply
into oil the bacteria also secrete
molecules called biosurfactants directly
into the membrane of the oil which
softens the boundary between the oil and
water
experimentally the researchers found
that the oil partially eaten by the
dendritic biofilm had lower interfacial
tension than the oil from the spherical
biofilm
secreting more biosurfactants could
contribute to that decrease which helps
the dendritic biofilm transform the
shape of the oil droplet
next the researchers delved into exactly
how these tubes form
the cells making up the spherical
biofilm can't deform the drop which
means that when the bacteria bump into
each other some cells are pushed outward
in contrast when dendritic forming
bacteria converge towards points on the
surface of the oil the pressure from the
bacteria dividing causes the surface to
buckle and a defect to form
eventually the bacteria pull and stretch
these defects into tubes filled with oil
by understanding how these defects form
the researchers were able to control
where the defects developed by changing
the shape of the draw
despite their different shapes the
dendritic and spherical biofilms
actually had similar total numbers of
bacteria and each individual bacterium
in both biofilms consumed oil at about
the same rate one cell volume per hour
yet the dendritic biofilm was able to
break apart the oil much faster forming
tubes of oil increase the surface area
of the oil in contact with the biofilm
allowing more bacteria to eat at the
same time there's still a lot left to
learn about how alkanovorax and other
oil-eating bacteria function out in the
open ocean as well as how they might
work alongside other traditional oil
cleanup strategies
what approach chemical dispersants break
up and coat the petroleum into smaller
droplets that sink into the ocean
although this helps prevent oil from
making it to shore it can potentially
harm marine organisms in the water
column
in the lab the researchers found that
this chemical caused the biofilm to slip
off the oil and return to its spherical
shape but this could unfold differently
under real life conditions
it's unlikely there will be a silver
bullet for cleaning up all oil spills
but in the future we may see stockpiles
of bacteria on the ready to gobble up
spills and leaks
[Music]